oh they're back the World Health
Organization you love them admit it
they're now warning of the potential of
another pandemic and buckle up it could
be 20 times worse than covid-19 anything
happening is a matter of when not if so
we need to have a placeholder for that
for the disase we don't know that may
come and that was when we gave the name
disiz
X oh my God even sounds like a complete
fiend doesn't he well but according to
the who director General his new Global
pandemic agreement which contains a lot
of really bad stuff is at risk of
falling apart the IMB and the IH working
group are operating amid a torrent of
fake News lies and conspiracy theories
we cannot allow this historic agreement
this milestone in global Health to be
sabotaged by those who spread lies are
either deliberately or
unknowingly well let me just tell you
the proposed treaty that has a deadline
of May
2024 it would give the wh control of
International Supply chains and it also
emphasizes race and Equity among other
things joining me now Dr Scott Atlas
Hoover institution's senior fellow
former Trump White House Co adviser now
Dr Atlas now when I hear him talk about
disease X you know there's nothing wrong
with you know idea of planning and
everyone be try to be prepared there's
nothing wrong with that but boy they
they shattered their credibility on so
many issues and most people you know
they they hear this and they they think
planemic that's what most people are
thinking
now well Laura you you've hit on
something here which is the shattering
the who has shattered trust in public
health agencies along with our own CDC
and our own leaders by the way why
because they issued pseudo science-based
mandates they issued erratic guidance
they had no transparency when it counted
when people were afraid and the the
reality is you're right the Accord is a
problem because it a circumvents
congress so there's no approval and it's
legally binding and the problem is not
just the mentions of equity more than a
dozen times and other social things it
defines Health Emergency in your country
and that's the Gateway for all kinds of
mandates that we've just lived through
it also regulates IP it requires
distribution it changes it affects
pricing of goods I mean no Sovereign
Nation would want to do that and the
problem is under this director Tedros
the wh is the greatest purveyor of
misinformation rivaling our own fou
Burks and our own CDC they back China's
lies that said there was no human human
transmission they praised China's
transparency in January uary 2020 and
February 2020 they literally backed
China covering up and blocking the who
itself from investigating the lab in
Wuhan Jan 21 and then yeah I mean this
is outrageous they called China tedro
specifically said China is a model of
pandemic management with the most
barbaric human rights violations you
know uh since we since in our modern
history by the way Tedros is a is a liar
in terms of being the health administer
before he was headed wh of Ethiopia when
he covered up a chalera outbreak this is
ridiculous it's absurd and they have a
dismal record for 15 years dating back
to H1N1 flu Ebola zika repeatedly
there's absolutely no uh sane reason why
we would sign on to something like that
we have leverage the who is funded by
many nations were the number one fun
$400 million plus per year of us
taxpayer money is funding them and the
bottom line is this number one no to
binding centralized agreements no to any
more funding at all to me for the who
until there's a change of leadership and
the biggest thing on the table with who
is we need to investigate what happened
and bring some accountability to their
gross incompetence and overt Mal
feasance all right Dr Atlas
accountability number one uh and that
includes fouchy and everyone else here
for what they did thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else